what's up guys the announcement has just
been made the oneplus 10 pro 5g is now
available i've had in my hands for the
past couple weeks of course we know it's
a 6.7 inch 120 hertz amoled display on
this you got the snapdragon 8 gen 1
processor 12 gigabytes of ram 256
gigabytes of storage on the unit i have
here and you can increase the ram make
it like vram up to seven gigabytes you
get up to 19 gigabytes of ram inside
this beast and i gotta tell you it's got
the second generation hasselblad cameras
what are my first impressions of this
phone this could be one of the best
android camera phones on the market
right now especially if you're a
hasselblad fan x-pen mode hasselblad pro
mode on this you've got those great
hasselblad colors ai 50 megapixel
cameras in this as well why telephoto
and standard this is a really impressive
phone for imaging i know there were some
concerns before i think oneplus has
addressed them our full review will be
coming soon on the all new oneplus 10
pro 5g